[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
yes I see hello and welcome everybody
so
um yes welcome welcome thank you Ruth
Ellen
um but you you take information
and you put it into world
practice folks so many times people will
go to college and get something that's
so General that yeah it might help them
in different areas of of life
but what is it doing to help the world
population that's what this doctor what
Dr Wallach has been doing for decades
including finding that there are over
diseases that are directly related to
nutritional deficiencies so think about
it you have a nutritional deficiency you
have this disease
well let's just fix the nutritional
deficiency and see if the disease takes
care of itself because the body can do
some amazing stuff and
more often than not the body does take
care of itself and Dr Wallach is here
with us today to share more information
on what we can do to live long healthy
lives folks not something that's being
dragged on by different medical
procedures and things that are just
helping us to
survive not Thrive Dr Wallach
welcome to
daily with Doc
well thank you Becca and thank you team
this is really as usual great to have
the family back after the holidays and
all that kind of stuff
and it was great to have a great
interview
with Theo Ratliff for a great basketball
star and so we're going to make that a
tool that's available to people right
yes we will so we're gonna go in we're
going to do some editing and make it
just perfect so we cut out all the
things that you don't need to hear
because it's not
beneficial to the message
and that's the thing about going live Dr
Wallach
you're going to have people it's going
to take them a little while to get
connected
you're going to have gaps and us and
um's and all of these things that come
with a live presentation and we're going
to take and make it beautiful and make
its flow and have it as a tool that'll
be available on the YouTube and Rumble
and Facebook critical Health news and
also
on dailywooddoc.com so you'll be able to
look for That interview with Dr Wallach
whether he's having a conversation with
MBA star theorem and this is really a
great great interview because at 21
years we work together and we took him
from a physical wreck I mean his career
was over okay and we rebuild him with
nutrition no drugs
and then he took it to other people
and took it around the world and the
story is just
leaves your breathless now when you
appreciate
that when you look at look at my books
um things like um oh
uh let's see here how's the kitchen you
look at
uh
let's go this one here another one of my
favorite prepare
okay repair there you go and in prepare
it tells you some facts
95 percent
of all Americans are nutritionally
deficient
okay this is right out of jam a general
American Medical Association 95 of all
Americans are nutritionally deficient
primarily mineral deficiencies primarily
mineral deficiency so taking a lot of
vitamin C when you have a mineral
deficiencies and that can really help a
lot okay then
they also came out and said
53 percent of medical doctors under oath
on the stand admit
that many of the treatments they give
are primarily to earn income as opposed
to cure the patient 53 okay this all and
and the
not only is are those statements in that
book okay prepare but it gives you the
reference so you can go and look it up
and read the whole article if you want
holy moly now what I want to do is use
that to begin the story
of
um human beings as we know them okay and
you you always hear about
um the biblical stories of people living
long time because they lived in the land
flowing with milk and honey I always
wondered you know we're the dairy cows
came from
3 000 years ago did they have big Barns
and milking machines no no no no no no
no no
and so I'm thinking I've been there I've
been to the Middle East oh and some of
these streams are white with minerals
you know grinding up Limestone and clay
and stuff like that and so these
minerals are suspended in the water make
it look like milk so we're talking about
the land flowing with milk and honey
it looks like milk but maybe the milk of
the Earth but it's not dairy milk it's
not cow's milk or llama milk or okay
wombat milk it's Earth milk okay so pay
attention to that so let's go back
okay to when I started keeping track of
this kind of stuff and let's go to
Methuselah one of my favorite people
Methuselah I'd like to talk to people
and say let's let's do it Methuselah did
Methuselah is famous for being one of
the longest lived people on record
969 years 969 years okay wow
um I think it was his grandson Jeremiah
lived to be 962 years and then Noah
lived to be
595 years Moses only lives to be 120
120. well it's still pretty good in
today's numbers but 120 is not as good
as 9.69
and then
now let's see here
um
in the Bible in the Old Testament God
said and manager shall be 120. well Adam
died at 930
Seth his son died at 912. enosh his son
died at 905 okay
and it's one of those things
to
which they say it just blows your mind
um how old these biblical characters
live to be and this is not difficult to
understand if you're eating perfectly
just like when you hear this story
of
of a Theo Ratliff with all the things he
had going wrong with him I mean this
guy's career was over when he was 24
years old we rebuilt him he played
that's fine
um 21 more years okay
and
did great things with much of his money
for the community as well as his own
family and so forth
but here's a guy who had lost everything
just after a couple years of playing pro
ball we rebuilt him just with nutrition
no drugs no surgery
no devices
and he stuck with it he stuck with it
okay most of them once they feel better
they stopped taking advantage bills they
fall down the hole again
well Theo did such a great job and so
that's why
we have you know we have this tool
coming out okay in the theater Ratliff
story and of course we do have all kinds
of of
um CDs and things that kind of touch
onto that stuff okay this is not
difficult to understand we do require
as vertebrates we require nutrients
nutritional minerals do not occur in a
uniform blank around the coast of the
earth occur in veins like gold and
silver plants do not make minerals
plants make vitamins you know this is
fatty acids
and we require 60 out of our 90
essential nutrients one-third are
minerals
so how did we get minerals for thousands
and thousands of years how did people
live to be 969
um how do they live to be
um 930 and all that kind of stuff how
did they do that 962 well they did that
okay I'm making sure that they were
um eating well and how did they do that
they didn't have refrigerators they
didn't have all that kind of stuff but
what they did have was wood for fuel and
coal for fuel and wood ashes and coal
ashes are 95 by weight minerals and two
or three percent by weight
carbon and they would put these wood
ashes and coal ashes into their Gardens
and the onions and the beets and the
peppers and tomatoes and and so forth
would suck up the minerals and people
would eat them and they get their
minerals that way
and of course we didn't have enough
money and when we were on the farm to
buy expensive spices so we put wood
ashes from this wood stove into our food
as because they're kind of spicy but we
got the minerals that way they're also
putting it directly into our food
and we got it that way you know and
people did pretty well well once we went
to electricity there were no more wood
ashes or coal ashes and in fact it even
got worse because the bottomland which
is renewing itself every year by
flooding okay we put up the the um dams
for hydroelectric and shut off this
annual flooding thing so there was no
more silt to renew the fields every year
on bottomland
and things really got bad
for about 20 years
and then doctors came out with all these
programs to help you be pain-free but
the disease kept getting worse and worse
and worse worse because they weren't
dealing with the disease or dealing with
symptoms again
in in this book prepare those in great
detail 53 on the stand of doctors when
asked the question
okay
about curing and doing procedures for
finances 53 said they do they choose
procedures based on the finances
and 95 percent
of all Americans are merely deficient so
this is very scary stuff okay so I
cannot thank Rebecca and her team enough
for helping us get this information out
there we do have Wellness public
occasions we do have www.drjwald.com
you get all my books and CDs and DVDs
and this don't forget the salt you want
to be the salt of the earth get our
seasoned salt from Australia New Zealand
get our Himalayan salt from the
Himalayan mountains or the hunzas
and they have this is not just
ground up
um salts okay from
um Ohio or anything like that
this is sea salt in both cases where the
Not only was there sodium chloride in
the seasoned salt from Australia New
Zealand and the Not only sodium chloride
in the Himalayan salt but this salt came
from Plants okay and and in in the
oceans thousands and thousands and
thousands of years ago when the oceans
disappeared all that salt
you know got accumulated in the valleys
and this is where we're getting we have
eight sources of this
um
Himalayan salt and seasoned salt
and we're getting all these minerals
that way and people are curing
a couple of thousand years ago a couple
of thousand years ago they were curing
goiter with sea salt they didn't know
what was in the sea salt that made the
glider go away but they knew the glider
went away when people used sea salt
okay because it had the minerals in
there
and so this is this is why in the old
days when people did something really
especially good for their family for
their community
they were known as the salt of the earth
because they were beneficial
okay
and so with that said I'm going to turn
this over to Rebecca
and see where else she wants to go here
well Dr Wallach there's a lot of people
with hands up so I think we need to go
right into answering questions the first
one I'm going to answer and this is
going to be a first I've learned that we
are able to unmute people that are on
the phone so I'm gonna unmute the person
area code 918 has a question so let's
see if we can get them to unmute unmute
hello can you hear us
hello can you hear me yes it worked
doctor well like so I understand you
have a question for us
yes Dr Wallach my husband is in a
nursing home and um he had lost 50
pounds and I was of course complaining
and so they put him on uh the ensure
product and of course I'm not into
ensure and they refused to respect my
wishes not to give you an answer anyway
they've been giving it to him like five
or six times a day and he's regained 20
pounds and of course the first
ingredient is uh water and then two
different forms of sugar and then milk
and then canola oil and anyway I would
like your perspective on how bad um and
why it's so bad and then if you can give
me any words of wisdom on how to get
them to not give it to him they're
saying it apart
huh how much does he weigh body weight
uh he is six foot uh four and he he now
weighs 200 pounds okay does he have any
other issues does he have diabetes does
he have a pressure does he have
arthritis
he has arthritis he has high blood
pressure he has dementia and those are
probably the main things
okay he's been died he's been diabetic
off and on but I don't know what they're
doing right now he hasn't been so bad so
anyway uh
all right I'll I'll shut up here okay
so
you need to get rid of all the bad foods
so it maximize absorption okay and of
course
um this ensure uh is not supposed to be
a total food intake you know six or
eight times a day no maybe one meal a
day or a dessert or something like that
okay and so you may want to look around
and find a different nursing home okay
you may want to look around say you know
maybe I'm just going to bring him home
and have
somebody come to my house and help him
okay so you have other options
you have to stay in that nursing home
this is America okay they're 200 pounds
let's get rid of all the bad foods get a
hold of my book Dr lunch cooking without
the bad foods 300 pages of safe recipes
safe cooking methods okay and then the
200 pounds I want him to have two
healthy branded heart packs per month
two Health abandoned heart facts for
months
um they contain 215 nutrients including
the 90 essential nutrients
they don't want to have two bottles a
month of our MSM so you take three at
breakfast three at lunch at dinner time
they're going to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between invertebrate bone rate
phone itself I want them to have two of
these canisters a month of the collagen
peptide so we can take a scoop of that
with those morning drink and scuba that
was this evening drink that's going to
help again rebuild cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disc between
invertebrate bone Rich bone itself
and then for the Highlight pressure I'm
going to get two bottles a month the
ultimate daily classic tablet says three
words ultimate daily classic tablets
take three twice a day or even three
three times a day he could and they're
going to support and promote healthy
blood pressure don't let him cold turkey
off of any blood pressure medications on
but as the blood pressure drops you can
slowly reduce the blood pressure
medication then because he has a history
on and off of having diabetes I do want
he may be a pre-diabetic I want him to
have our sweeties get two bottles a
month of that amount so I can take three
twice a day that'll support healthy
blood sugar these only blood sugar
issues um blood medications don't pull
turkey off of them yeah you know
instantly and any kind of stuff for pain
on his joints he could use a CM cream
and also
uh we have our hemp effect sued okay I
use both of those when I need it you
know I was shoveling stuff out in the
yard or lifting stuff loading unloading
trucks and things you know get a little
shoulder thing here an elbow thing there
um and so I'll use the CM cream which
lasts for maybe two to three hours okay
topical pain reliefs the uh hemp FX2
that lasts for I don't know five six
seven eight hours okay and so I might if
I strain my shoulder or something like
that I'll use a soothe before I go to
bed so I don't have to wake up in the
middle of the night and put something on
and so but keep in touch with us because
all of his issues can go away because
none of these are genetic none of these
are autoimmune they're simply
nutritional deficiencies and he's got to
stay away from all the bad foods that's
why we want you to get that book it's
got the good bad food list in there 300
pages of safe recipes and safe cooking
methods and the good good bad food list
no fried foods no processed Meats no
oils no glutens no wheat and oats there
are no such things as gluten-free oats
the gluten in oats is called gliadin but
they're still gluten no buckwheat
there's no gluten in buckwheat but they
do have Faygo fago Pirates which are
worse than gluten no sugar no carbonated
drinks that includes soft drinks okay
diet drinks and also carbonated water
because carbonation neutralizes the
stomach acids so you cannot absorb
minerals or digest food so do give us a
call every couple of weeks because
you're going to have a great story we
see people with this little scenario
over and over and over all over the
world because they are mineral
deficiencies
and mental deficiencies since we went to
electricity have been the biggest
which they say Nemesis of humanity
okay so with that back to you Rebecca
so Dr Wallach um ensure is like a meal
replacement which meal replacement
offered by youngevity would you
recommend
which one would you choose
well I really like well my mom really
likes the plant-based protein shape it's
vanilla she can add fruit to it
um and make it whatever flavor she wants
but she just likes it as the vanilla
also
I like the fact Dr Wallach that one it
goes by
The Good Foods bad foods list
it's not adding in all these oils and
sugars
it's natural from our stay natural line
and it's doing more than just adding
calories it's actually adding and
nutrition it's not taking the place of
the 90 essential nutrients but it is
acting
adding additional
um
yes absolutely so with what Dr Wallach
just recommended I I would add to that
the plant-based
um protein shake we also have the total
meal replacement shakes that can be used
also for meal replacements not in
addition to a meal but unless you need
to gain weight but meal replacements
so okay thank you very much all right
well thank you Dr Wallach and I'm glad
that Zoom has allowed that option to be
able to unmute a caller so
um thank you Ruth Ellen for letting me
know that we had a caller that had a
question because she called into our 809
855-949-3377 that is the daily with Doc
call in line and this is for getting
onto the program or for those who have
never spoken to anybody about youngevity
before and here Dr Wallach there you go
you're not all by yourself anymore I've
got to get back into the routine of this
Dr Wallach take a few days off and I
gotta remember it's just like riding a
bike right
but anyways
um folks if you're on live with us and
you would like to ask a question if you
go to the zoom menu click on reactions
under reactions there is the option to
raise hand
so I want to make sure that we get to
all the hands Dr Wallach and we had a
lady that was on over an hour early and
she has her hand up so I would like to
call on Lynn Lynn go ahead and unmute
yourself
are you there Lynn
I see you're unmuted
Lynn
oh Lynn go back out and come back in I'm
your audio did not connect
so we'll get back to you we're gonna
move right over but Lynn go out come
back in and usually not fix the problem
okay
thank you
let's go over to the next town that is
up Dr Wallach and that is Rosemary
Rosemary go ahead and unmute yourself
thank you Dr Wallach I have a client
who's on the 90 I've never been able to
get her on anything else but she does
take the 90. and her doctor has told her
that she can only take a multiple
and calcium and she cannot take any um
she should not take any uh collagen
because she has her thyroid has been
removed
is that true
no she's a change doctors yeah I agree
yeah
but if she's had her thyroid removed we
have what's called Ocean's gold and a
few coins Z two different oceans each
one has I don't know eight or nine
different seaweeds in them then we also
have a liquid form of fucoid Z called Z
radical I know that's Rebecca's favorite
looks and tastes like red wine but
there's no alcohol in it okay it's
really great stuff we have you know a
couple ounces for breakfast couple
ounces for dinner okay that's going to
help
um with more nutrients okay does she
have any particular health issues she's
had both she's had both of her breasts
removed two different times but at
different times excuse me during times
how do you grow
one breast at a time one breast
maybe 20 years ago and the other one
more like five years ago
um
and other than that the thyroid it's
about all that she has
yeah I I'd her take that Z radical and
also the view quite Z and the
um oceans gold along with how much does
she weigh is she a big girl or small or
she's about five nine 130 pounds 130
pounds yeah okay yeah she's right at
that cusp I'm assuming she had her
breast removed because she had cancer
yes okay and I would give her two
healthy brain and heart faster a month
for those everything twice a day
there's 215 nutrients including the 90.
I would also have her take
um the MSM uh she can take three of
those at breakfast lunch and dinner will
be two bottles a month that's going to
support her immune system including
rebuilding cartilage and ligaments and
tendons skin
all that kind of stuff but also supports
rebuilding the bone marrow which is
where your immune system is your white
blood cells and that kind of stuff okay
then let's see here
uh I would also
let's see here
that's kind of where I would go
that's that's where I would go for her I
wouldn't hurt for her to go ahead and
also take our rebound or sports drinks
she could go ahead and take that but you
have the sticks we have the canisters we
have the cams uh the sticks and the
cancers do not have carbonation they
can't do have carbonation you got to pop
the tops on them put in the refrigerator
at night drink them the next day
but my rebound per serving has a hundred
nutrients in it
75 minerals and 25 vitamins amino acids
so it's a great great you know energy
drink it's a great supplement
okay and so and the collagen is okay
and yeah collagen is absolutely okay
it's kind of like saying you can't use
oxygen the iron in your body might rust
okay thank you yeah okay
so when doctor says stuff like that it's
time to start investigating the options
you know you can look for another doctor
right
thank you you bet thank you keep us
informed how is y'all does okay
thank you Rosemary now Dr Wallach out in
YouTube land Blossom has a question
and we need somebody to mute
okay let's try that now
um so she has a 16 month old that's
about 20 pounds and is having a tough
time keeping him hydrated he's
constipated and noticed that his waist
is very dry would you recommend BTT is
her question and my question for extra
hydration would you recommend adding the
strawberry kiwi men's to water so that
he's getting minerals throughout the day
in water that tastes good okay now is
this a human being
uh yeah 16 month old little boy okay 20
pounds
okay
um yeah I would add the kids toddy for
one serving a day
okay and then of course
um
there's all kinds of liquid stuff we
have
but the kids tiny
in the efas
maybe FK pluses
um
it's a little too soon for the rebound
but what do you think what would you
think in addition to the kids toddy
well something that really helps with
constipation Dr Wallach is the caltati
and I know that the kids toddy has some
calcium and magnesium in there so if
he's not on that that might do the trick
but if that doesn't do the trick adding
even just a half or a quarter of a
teaspoon at 20 pounds may do the trick
to help
get his moving get him moving so he's
not constipated but again that
strawberry kiwi men's added to water
tastes really good and it's more it's
like electrolyte drink for babies so
instead of doing that drink that starts
with a P for kids to get them hydrated
adding the strawberry kiwi men's or the
Cherry mints to water
is a much better idea Dr Wallach okay
very good
all right and then we have a email
coming in from Jamie Jamie wants to know
what causes the human body to feel like
it's vibrating numb tingling off balance
and wobbly at times
stiffness and achy joints possible
um
she says is it possible somebody has too
many positive ions and needs negative
ions how can the body stay balanced with
the right amount of ions well Dr Wallach
it's nutrition that we're missing that's
causing all of these things right and
you're holding up the book it's all in
your head which I have a copy of right
here and I'll go ahead and turn it to
your favorite page for you okay page six
Roman numeral front end
so front end before the numbers start
yeah there you go top skull is normal
Quantum and stick bottom skull is has
osteoporosis it's an inch and a half to
two inches thick it squeezes the 12
pairs of cranial nerves and the spinal
cord giving you 37 different diseases
okay in symptoms
and um doctors know nothing about this
I've had patients try and tell their
doctor about and the doctor just gets
something walks out of the room because
they don't get training on osteoporosis
of the skull okay
and so again this is a case where they
need per 100 pounds of body weight uh
one healthy drain in heart pack per
month they only weigh 110 pounds be a
half a dose or anything twice a day if
they weigh 150 or more it's two Health
abandoned heart factors a month full of
those trading twice a day an easy MSM if
they only weigh 110 pounds be one bottle
a month so you can take three twice a
day if they weigh 130 500 40 150 pounds
or more get two miles a month to the MSM
so you take three the breakfast street
lunch at dinner time that's gonna
rebuild cartilage and ligaments and
tendons and connective tissue and disc
between the vertebrae and bone matrix
and all that kind of stuff including the
skull okay all is vibrating tinnitus
ringing in the ears and balance problems
and squeezing the auditory branch of the
atrial nerve and the vestibular branch
of the atrial nerve also they can get
any regular heartbeat called atrial
fibrillation they get a fast heart rate
which is called tachycardia a slow heart
rate which is called bradycardia all
squeezing the the
um 10th cranial nerve the vagus nerve
also in the 10th cranial nerve the
vacation squeeze you get extreme stomach
pain okay
um let's see here
it's called uh what is it uh
gastroparesis yeah there you go again
gastroparesis gastroparesis thank you
gastroparesis okay and all these are
totally preventable and reversible
um by taking the nutrients and the
formula
okay the big one the hell the brain
heart pack is in the book and the CD set
that we made you and Dr melanomy okay
and uh it's and it's all in your head
that's a great great book which sells
like crazy uh because it covers things
the doctors know nothing about
doctors know nothing about osteoporosis
of the skull 130.
yeah it's only like 30 pages so it's not
like a big textbook but folks the stuff
that is in here
is kind of like the the cliff notes
of what a textbook would be that gives
you just the important stuff the stuff
that you need to know the stuff that you
need to remember and it's written so
that it can be understood and retained
and the importance of
think about it
the skull is bone
how can you not have arthritis affecting
the skull if you've got arthritis in
every single joint of the body
well here's why because doctors if you
have stuff going on in your knees they
can do a double knee replacement you
have stuff going on your hips they do
double hip replacement well if you have
osteoporosis of the skull
do you do a double head replacement
I do know people that have had parts of
their skull removed and then put a metal
plate in because it's not right and we
don't have to do that
just remember
that uh
let's see here the note says okay
and this is in Jama German American
Medical Association 50 on the stand
under a 53 percent of medical doctors
America recommend treatments they're
more valuable from an income standpoint
than a treatment standpoint
all right folks you heard it and it's
reported
let's go ahead and help people and
Empower them to make decisions that can
allow them to avoid those expensive
surgeries and procedures and keep in the
pockets
absolutely
absolutely they can just lead to more
and more treatments that are needed to
maintain or regain any type of regular
function
Dr Wallach let's go to Renee who has her
hand up Renee
uh-oh where'd you go
go ahead and unmute yourself Renee
howdy hi hello
um I have been taking the supplements
for a while
and I just had a blood test from my
doctor and he has raised my thyroid
medicine
because I keep gaining weight
and I hardly eat any food
um I have Guillain Beret and
Epstein-Barr
and your supplements have really helped
with my stomach issues of
not being able every morning I would get
up and get sick
and never be hungry and it has helped
but I'm stuck where now my legs are
really swelling
and so how much you weighed
okay and how old are you
58. did you say 68 58 58 okay and how
tall are you
five six five six okay if I have six I'd
like to see away 120 140
see maybe 150 pounds overweight
and this is because you're minimally
deficient I want you to get a hold of
the book Rare Earth have been cures rare
Earth's been cures
www.drjwalk.com
wwe.com get a hold of my book rare
there's been cures go to chapters 10 11
page 272 and Rebecca's holding up the
book it'll it'll tell you how to collect
the hair where to ship it don't forget
to put a check in there you don't need a
doctor's prescription permission to get
a hair analysis we will walk you through
this
um and tell you exactly what you need
okay and it also will tell if you have
any toxic Metals there's I think five
charts in there one chart is is the
nutritional minerals one chart is the
toxic Metals the other three charts are
ratio of things
um but anyway you need to find out
exactly what's going on here so we're
not guessing because there's 60
essential minerals you know which ones
are you missing causing all these
problems and so those hair analysis will
tell you specifically again you don't
need a prescription you don't need your
doctor to approve it he won't understand
it so when you get the results
contact us we'll walk you through this
we charge you nothing we don't charge
any fees or anything for interpreting it
for you okay
well and another problem is I have
really low cholesterol
and are you eating eggs for breakfast
well I'm trying I I'm not eating as many
as you say I should okay are you eating
are you taking your I-26
never heard of that okay I-26 I like the
tools they come in tablets they come in
powder and chewables I like the
chewables
um the little kids like them because
they taste like um vanilla ice cream and
they're not crunchy things they're just
you bite one and they just turn into
powder okay okay it's kind of nice it
tastes like vanilla ice cream so I take
two of those at lunch time because they
have three eggs for breakfast and drinks
for dinner somehow there's some kind of
interference between one another
and I want you to get our keto Shake
okay I want to get our keto shake and
take one keto shake meal a day it's a
meal replacer it's not to add to a meal
to me replace her we haven't Chomp and
strawberry and so I want you to get half
the month is going to be strawberry half
the must be chocolate and kind of mix it
up
um okay today we're gonna have
strawberries two days in a row you might
have chocolate in three days in a row we
might have strawberry then you go back
to chocolate and so forth so you're
mixing it up right and let's see here
let's I'm gonna put Rebecca on the spot
here how much weight did you lose going
through that process and and using the
the keto Shake uh Becca
well I altogether Dr Wallach I've lost
just over a hundred pounds
um probably about 60 of that was doing
the keto program
and I personally like half strawberry
half chocolate
you mix them at the same time mix them
at the same time so half a scoop of
strawberry half a scoop of chocolate but
I also follow a ketogenic diet which is
low carbohydrates and high in good fats
and moderate in in our moderate protein
yeah so make your fat fat does not make
you fat right is mineral deficiencies
mineral deficiencies make you fat
because it drives you to a behavior
called Pica which causes you to eat and
eat and eat and eat and eat looking for
those minerals but once you start taking
the minerals that Pica goes away and
you'll lose a half a pound of two pounds
a day okay without even trying
so basically your your
chips are just butter is that what
you're telling me that's right butter is
your main fat you know animal fat
chicken fat steak fat hamburger
yeah don't choose don't make don't make
lean choices you know I've always I've
always peeled off the skin
and the gentleman that was helping me
with with uh
ordering stuff said no no that's your
best part to keep is the skin and and
that and it's I just have a hard time
eating it because I just
have all these years not eaten it
but well let's think about the skin okay
like cures like when we're in an herbal
world
so with the skin being
fat and collagen what is your skin
fat and collagen so it feeds the body
and just gives it more of what it needs
in order to maintain what it has or
regain what it has
I love the keto bar I I know I'm sad
that you guys got rid of that but
um Joe Shake there's some with the keto
Shake I ordered that and in because of
my Guillain-Barre
I don't know why it's
I don't know if there's a connection or
what but after I drink the shake it's
like my legs turn to cement okay the
Jamboree is the same thing as Ms in the
in the brain
okay it says Ms and the spinal cord and
if you can't eat three eggs twice a day
then eat one egg twice a day if you
start there you know soft scrambled in
butter okay but then get that I-26 and
take two of those at lunch time the the
chewables it tastes like vanilla ice
cream
and then one keto Shake
one keto shaped meal let's say did you
have just one keto shake meal per day
Becca I will with my program I did
fasting where in the beginning I had
four keto shakes no no food but four
keto shakes plus my supplementation
um I had one week that I lost eight
pounds in that week we have people that
Dr well like they're losing 18 pounds in
that first week and then they start
doing two shakes and meal replacement
shakes and then go down to one meal
replacement shake but they're still
following that
75 25
ratios so 75 fats 25 and this is of
calories
25 of protein and then five percent of
carbohydrates or is it grams grams
um
but
so Renee with having the Gian Beret what
Dr Wallach is recommending is you need
that cholesterol your low cholesterol is
because you're having these issues with
the I-26 it also comes in a powder that
you can add to your shake your keto
shake you can add it to your Beyond
tangy tangerine and make sure that
you're getting those additional dosages
of the I-26 hyper immune that's going to
give you that good cholesterol that your
body's starving for
so if you don't want to do the chewables
there's the powder yeah one dose of the
um I-26 gives you 25 percent of your
daily requirement of cholesterol
well that'll be good it says
that freaks everybody out
I'll have to look at that
um and um
also what makes you want to itch your
skin off all the time
well here's again where you want that
MSM and the collagen peptides your skin
is the biggest reservoir of collagen and
connective tissue in your body
two-thirds of the skin is connective
tissue just like your tendons and
ligaments and cartilage and stuff like
that is your skin
okay and that's why
all the old Wildlife hunters and stuff
like that you know and would eat the
skin of the animals uh that way they're
um they didn't know why but it made him
you know they didn't have arthritis and
stuff because that's where they're
getting the raw mature they're getting
the collagen to rebuild their
cholesterol and not cholesterol excuse
me they're um
all of their things that made out of
collagen okay you know like tannins and
ligaments and
um skin the hair the skin hair
heart valves
bone matrix even bones The Matrix where
the minerals sit on is made out of
collagen
all right
okay all right Renee
thank you thanks for coming on
so
Dr Wallach we have a question or we're
going to go back to Lynn actually
um Lynn go ahead and unmute and I
actually have her question if we aren't
able to hear her this time
I am not hearing her but her question is
Dr Wallach
um she's been diagnosed with medium
level dry macular degeneration she's
been told to damage to the macula cannot
be healed she wants to know can the
damage of the macula be healed she is
very anxious to heal it rather than just
try to slow or stop the decline as the
doctors tell me is the best I can hope
for I can still see well with some
issues
so Lynn say something can I hear you
oh no I still cannot hear her Dr Wallace
okay so if he she obviously can hear us
that's the main thing okay here we go so
now you have to appreciate the macula is
in the lining the retina of the eye
right around where the optic nerve goes
into the back of the eye
okay so we have Max regeneration
you have osteoporosis of the skull
squeezing the optic nerve in the optic
gardening optic vein shutting off the
food supply to that macula okay I'm
slowly dying because the skull is slowly
squeezing the optic nerve in the optic
Arena optic vein okay now
do you have any ringing in your ears you
have any tinnitus arena in your ears
okay do you have any balance phones any
dizziness or balance problems
okay yeah the skull is squeezing the
vestibular branch of the age cranial
nerve causing that dizziness and balance
problems and then also uh let's see here
um what's another one oh how many times
a night do you wake up to urinate do you
wake up once three times once three
times five times
once or twice a night yeah yeah you have
osteoporosis of the skull that's what's
causing the max regeneration the skull
is squeezing an optic nerve and you need
to get a hold of the book and the CD set
it's on your head and you can go to
um the the pages are about optic nerve
which is optic nerve number two okay
okay cranial nerve number two the optic
nerve okay and it'll tell you the story
and again uh it's a set it's a CD and
the book this is osteoporosis of the
skull this is a normal skull vitamin
stick an inch and a half two inches
thick you can see it be squeezing the
um
spinal cord is spinal cord showing the
urinary bladder to urinate uh that's why
you're urinating once or twice a night I
know it's not a prostate problem because
girls don't have prostates okay I don't
even have to do an exam on you you're a
girl no prostate that's easy
okay and I don't know why doctors just
don't get that they need to go back to
go back to anatomy class okay okay so
um yeah the max regenerate Max
regeneration is will respond to this
approach and the vision will come back
uh oh also you want to throw in
are occupative oh my gosh I was getting
a Max regeneration in my uh left and my
right eye my right eye I mean I have to
get new glasses because I really don't
need glasses anymore okay so when you
see me next time it'll either be
different glasses or no glasses because
the occupative I take three twice a day
along with all my other supplements and
I could tell within a week suddenly now
that
um macula was healing because suddenly
now all the stuff that had gone away had
come back it was the good stuff all came
back
okay
all right thank you Lynn
thank you for bearing with us glad we
could get that question asked for you we
have time for one more Dr Wallach let's
go to Cameron Cameron go ahead and
unmute yourself
all right Dr wallet can you hear me yes
sir yes sir yes we can all right okay so
I am
29 years old
um I'm in great health
I weigh about 173 pounds
um and I have heard about your I've read
most of your books I've put my family on
your regimen and had great success
so I have started doing the same exact
thing for myself
um and I've cut out all the oils and
originally weighed 185 and it had lost
12 13 pounds
and
um there's only one negative
symptom that I'm having since I've
started all of this regimen and I'm
losing weight I feel good working out
but there's like a heaviness on my chest
like a tightness in my chest and it's
not there all the time it's there
sometimes and I'm eating about a stick
of butter
I need to answer this question quickly
here
um
basically you say you weigh a hundred
and
seventy three 173 pounds okay 100 pounds
I want you to have two healthy brain and
heart pressure amounts photos saying
twice a day I also want you to take two
bottles a month for MSM so you take
three at breakfast three lunch at dinner
time I want you to take your collagen
peptides and scuba that with your
morning drinks with your evening drink
obviously have two doses of a rebound a
day you want a breakfast one at lunch
one at lunch I kind of take with lunch
and then I have as a snack you know sort
of mid-afternoon I don't take it at
night because you'll be up all night
unless you're gonna be driving all night
carrying a partying all night then it's
okay and we do have the powder there's
um 30 of these sticks in a box okay
there's a hundred nutrients in here 75
minerals and 25 items amino acids and
there's 36 servings in the canister we
do have the cans which I drink at night
all right well I don't drink and I pop
the tops on them okay and put the their
seal puts it okay I pop the chops put
two of them in the refrigerator at night
so I drink one with breakfast and then
one with lunch and the end of the
afternoon okay and then I take the
sticks with me when I go out to eat at
night when I go visit other people so I
don't take the cans with me and spill
all over the car so I just take these
with me you can just tear the top off
put them in a bottle of water and you
get your 100 nutrients okay that way and
the energy will be there and
it'll help give you more and I do this
along I only weigh 142 pounds
and I take two other branded hard packs
plus all these other nutrients I
probably take 40 other different
nutrients but I also take the rebound
and
um
it's one of those things where
it's um amazing it's amazing you know
what your body can do when it gets to
nutrition okay so give us a call every
couple of weeks because you're going to
have a great story I appreciate that
last last little bit thing because I
know you got to get going but I've never
had this sent them before and it wasn't
until I started eating all this butter
would that be the the reason while I'm
having
uh chest pain not chest pain but
heaviness
no if you're having
um tightness in the chest kind of say oh
thank you for that I want you to have
the ultimate daily classic house I I got
disrupted there okay ultimate daily
classic channels take three of those
twice a day they're designed to support
healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries through
um and also supporting healthy blood
pressure uh do you have a normal blood
pressure
yes well I did until recently I don't
know what it is now okay we'll check it
out but anyway the ultimate daily
classic channels take three twice a day
that's what I do as some of the other
tablets I take in addition to the
healthy Brandon hard pack and the
rebound and all that kind of stuff
and
you know people say well watch you know
the only the only way
142 pounds why are you taking so much
stuff well
in 200 years let's see which one of us
is still here
you're right no I totally understand
okay totally understand and you know
I will say this I mean you're going on
84 years old and I know plenty of uh 65
year olds that you know don't have the
cognitive function that you that you
have you're really quick so they
wouldn't be able to stand up in a fist
fight with me either okay I'm saying
you're right I believe it I read your
book I know that uh you'll go to Tony
with somebody yeah I I you know wrestled
I played football weight lifted ran
track boxed and so uh if it's in the
military for over 20 years retires
lieutenant colonel in the Air Force so
you know I know how to handle myself and
so there's a couple guys they try to
take my bag of goodies in the um Mall
there are three guys and one of them I
got him on the floor and just beat the
snot out and the other two ran away
streaming I still had my stuff okay
yeah I believe you I yeah I think I
remember that in your book but that's
yeah that's amazing real quick I know we
got a second so so is it the ginkgo leaf
and the Hawthorne Berry that that helps
out with the heart because I know that
the cardio FX have that as well okay no
it's this whole thing don't try and pick
out a nutrient or herb or something like
that so you can go get that one nutrient
or that one herb don't don't go there
that's not the way it works right okay
if you're gonna have a wonderful tasting
cake
are you only going to take the
blueberries in the cake are you going to
take the whole recipe oh recipe the
whole recipe okay you got it all right
same way here do not I used to tell
people what the nutrient was and then
I'd call and say Julie whatever happened
to you and Frank
okay haven't heard anything for a couple
of months well Frank died three months
after you told him to take that one
nutrient he took that one nutrient for
three months and then he died but did
you take the others no he just took that
one nutrient and so I stopped telling
people what they want nutrient notes
right Dr Wallach
they're gonna fire me because you're
gonna be late for your next appointment
let's go I gotta run thanks Dr willick I
appreciate it talk to you later thank
you so much Cameron thank you Dr Wallach
um and folks I know that many of you
have their hands up there's questions
that are in the chat that I apologize we
did not get to today some people have
emailed in their questions we are going
through and answering those questions
and in the order that they are being
received and yes if I can get my
wonderful co-hosts on with me because
they are helping me go through all of
these questions you know it has been
overwhelming the response that we have
received with people empowering
themselves or having the desire to
empower themselves to take their health
into their own hands and get natural
options that are going to feed the body
instead of chemically destroy the body
and that's what we do as holistic health
coaches we help coach you in a way that
helps meet those needs that are shown
because of all of the symptoms of
deficiency
so get back with the person that shared
this program with you
tell them what's going on ask them and
if they're a certified holistic health
coach they should have a health
evaluation system that goes through and
asks many of the questions more than
what Dr Wallach has the time to answer
here
he asked the this evaluation asks the
questions that Dr Wallach has asked in
the past when he was doing his clinics
on symptoms that you're having
each of those symptoms and some of them
may sound kind of silly to ask but each
of those symptoms are directly connected
through
three different pathologies or
post-doctorates and pathology
and then clinical
implementation
and finding those deficiencies linking
them with the symptoms correcting the
deficiency and somehow those symptoms
just kind of melt away that did for me I
know it did for many of my co-hosts as
well or people within their family and
we are just so honored to be able to
present to you daily with Doc Monday
through Friday except for when I need a
vacation
and
without before I forget the content of
this program is to provide nutritional
education only it is not meant to take
the place of your primary care physician
and this is to show you as an empowered
individual
whether the FDA wants you to know it or
not
you have options available
so again get back with the person that
shared this program with you if we did
not get to your question feel free to go
to daily withdoc.com use that contact us
send us an email and we will get back to
you with a response based on the
research and findings of Dr Joel Wallach
so until next time I want to give a
special shout out to Ruth Ellen Sanchez
I mean
she she keeps me on track
and she makes all of this stuff in the
background go
like for those of you who are on YouTube
and if you've got questions on YouTube
she makes sure that I get the questions
and we get to those as we can and Rumble
and Facebook I mean it takes a whole
group of people to make this happen and
folks if you have ever thought of
becoming a certified holistic health
coach and having that additional income
stream
through coaching and also through
providing options and solutions that the
youngevity options have provided for
myself and each of us
get back with the person that shared
this program with you if there is nobody
to think please go to daily withdoc.com
and use that contact us and say I want
to coach and we will get you connected
with our coaching program we'll get you
hooked up with one of our coaches as a
mentor and we will together help heal
communities and the world Sherry
Browning thank you so much for helping
everybody get into the the meeting
Marilyn thank you for all of your
wonderful notes that you put in the chat
and next time tomorrow
if it's a weekday and you're out on
YouTube or rumble or Facebook and you
want to join us here in the live meeting
go to daily with
doczoom.com all together daily with Doc
zoom.com and my name is Becca dukes and
as your host of this program I invite
you to come back
and check out the replays also on each
of those platforms and I'm going to stop
now because I could talk forever bye for
now
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]